this is Operation Kingslayer listen up
our field of operation is Bolivia
dense jungles freezing mountains and
salt flats
if you don't watch your back you won't
leave it alive your target is the Santa
Blanca drug cartel their Network relies
on fear violence and intimidation you'll
need to destroy them from the inside
destabilize each aspect of their
operations production smuggling
influence and security to bring them to
their knees you have full autonomy you
pick your targets you decide how to take
them out just get it done
gather your Intel learn who the players
are learning methods
and destroy them
to make this OP a real party the local
military force
Unni dad are on the cartels payroll
they've been fighting it out with a
low-rent rebel group called the
guitarist 26 you want to survive he's
under funded and under equipped rebels
are your new best friends you got to
think you gotta be strategic
no one will come when you call for help
use what you can to get the job done
you have your arsenal and every vehicle
you can find at your disposal and don't
be afraid to throw out the PlayBook each
of you is an elite war fighter but
together you have the strength to take
down an army
and remember ghosts credits this failure
you will burn the Santa Blanca drug
cartel to the ground but no one will
know who was holding the match
[Music]